I downloaded the GAPS diet protocol from Dr. Campbell's website since chicken is on the yellow zone for me
but I have to have bone broth. I use holy bones. Yes. So do I remove the meat from the drumsticks or
something before I make the broth? Yeah, this is something you're going to have to do. Now again,
so the GAPS diet is using bone broth and you have antibodies to just about every meat that is on the list
there. Maybe it was lamb on the list, maybe a meat that you could buy elsewhere, you could make
the bone broth out of. Also, you could use, you could not use, you could choose to not make bone broth
and just use a gut healing protocols that we talked about, deglycerized licorice, glutamine,
aloe, some of the things that are in that, that clear GI product might as the things that you're
sensitive to. So there's some good protocols on the store that have some gut healing things and
buy some of those and use those things and you go in anti-inflammatory diet that way. You don't
need to use bone broth. What's the purpose of doing bone broth with the GAPS diet? The purpose of
doing bone broth in the GAPS diet is to get glutamine, period. What's so healing about drinking
bone broth? What's so healing about drinking bone broth? Healing as far as your gut goes, it's the
glutamine. Now, typically, we tell cancer patients not to take glutamine, not to increase
aloe glutamine, not to take supplements with aloe glutamine. In your case, we have to set that aside,
we need to start healing the gut. This is going to be long-term. You're not going to be doing this
for a year or something. Hopefully, it's going to be just weeks to months. And then, as your gut
starts to calm down, then maybe we can add some of the things in the yellow and maybe one of the things
in the yellow we want to add is chicken. Maybe that'll be the first thing we add, and maybe we will
make some chicken soup out of the chicken. It will use not just the bone broth from the chicken,
because we're going to make chicken soup the right way by putting a whole organic chicken in a pot
and filling the pot with water and bringing it to a boil and then simmer it all day long,
and then takes chicken off while the meat falls apart and chop up the meat, put it back in there,
add some vegetables that are in the green section of your Syrex 10 and make a chicken soup.
And maybe that's how you're going to start this after maybe three weeks of not having any bone broth,
but using aloe glutamine and using deglycerized licorice and using aloe and using
some of those other products that we discussed. So this is the creativity that you're going to have
to come up with in trying to heal your gut. Everybody's different. So some people, like I said,
have really damaged gut lineings, and that may be the thing that caused the cancer in the first place
because of this hyperinflammatory state. So causing working at decreasing systemic inflammation
is what you really want to be working towards. So it's not easy always, but
nobody said life was going to be easy, I hate to say, but sounds a little coarse, but
we all go through it. There's a reason why God lets things happen in our life that are difficult and
it's to drive us to a deeper relationship with Him. And you're either going to let, you know,
you're going to, and I'm not talking about you, individual, all of us are either going to let
our struggles in our life drive us to that deeper relationship with Him, but a deeper trust in Him
or it's going to make us bitter and angry and miserable human beings, and then we've kind of failed
the test. Okay, so I just eat stuff on the green zone and the herbals. I can do this. I just wanted
to make sure the broth wasn't mandatory. No, no, it's not mandatory. Just what is mandatory is
you're adding the things that we talked about that are going to be gut healing. Like the glutamine
added as a supplement then. It's not expensive. Like you said, you had a deaclycerized liquor,
add that, start with that, you have that. So add some of those things to start healing the gut,
call me to tell you're going to start feeling better, and that's going to be encouraging to you. So
I just got to view it as I'm going to do everything that I know to do that's right, and trust
God for those results. Also run your right on some anti-inflammation programs. That would be healing.
So run the accelerated healing program. It's a the normalizing frequency folder.
That could be healing for all sorts of less low skeletal and tissue issues. That could heal
soft tissue. So that's one of my favorite programs on the right. It's in the normalizing frequency
folder, and it's called accelerated healing. So it does wonders. I've shared multiple times how
healed my torn rotator cuff in my shoulder, just like miraculously. So it could heal, help heal
your gut too. So run those programs.